dans les phrases d'artillerie rues sont
permanentes un jour et nuit ici à
kharkhiv on entend des explosions de
manière très très régulières parfois à
s'éloigner parfois beaucoup plus proches
comme il ya environ trente minutes nous
avons entendu une énorme déflagration
qui provenait semble-t-il des quartiers
nord de la ville alors nous sommes
actuellement dans le dans le sud de la
ville qui est relativement épargnée même
s'il ya eu des immeubles qui ont été
détruits ici pas loin mais le nord de la
ville est extrêmement frappé extrêmement
deux touchés par l'artillerie russe
alors selon les autorités et bien selon
un million de ce matin les dernières 24
heures dans toute la région de kharkiv
il y avait eu 47 frappe de l'artillerie
russe et 380 frappes de missiles grad et
domicile ce match plus récemment la
aujourd'hui il y a eu dans un quartier
nord qui s'appelle satif cas au moins
une dizaine de frappes contre des
immeubles résidentiels
donc dans ce quartier de satish cas ce
qu artiste atika nous y étions justement
hier après midi nous avons pu passer
quelques heures avec les habitants de ce
quartier du moins avec ceux qui ne sont
pas partis et ils sont extrêmement rares
il s'agissait vraiment d'une poignée
d'habitants pour la plupart des
personnes âgées qui voulaient rester
chez elle et qu'ils ne voulaient pas
partir aller se cacher dans le métro
comme l'ont fait la plupart des
habitants de sa tige cas alors
évidemment ce quartier porte sur tous
les immeubles les stigmates de cette
guerre il ya de très nombreux immeubles
frappé détruit incendiaient ce sont des
carcasses de bâtiments calcinés et des
tiers qui sont constants des explosions
constante nous avons pu par exemple
parlé avec plusieurs personnes qui à
chaque nouvelle frappe course terrer
dans des abris souterrains bâti au fond
de ces bâtis à sousse et immeubles l'une
des personnes que nous avons rencontrées
s'appelle ludmilla elle à environ 75 ans
si tu donnes extrêmement digne qui était
pendant très longtemps professeur de
piano qui enseignait la musique à des
enfants et donc chaque fois que les
bombardements reprenait avec sa canne
ludmila repartait se terrer dans son
abri souterrain extrêmement rudimentaire
tout de même équipé d'une télévision
très de trait qui lui permettait de
suivre les informations en temps réel
sur diffusé par la télévision
ukrainienne alors ludmilla nous disait
eh bien que son père s'était battu lors
de la bataille de stalingrad pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale et qu'elle
n'aurait jamais cru que poutine allait
faire quelque chose comme ça et qu'il
était en train de créer à kharkhiv une
deuxième stalingrad